hey Vsauce Michael here and today we are
going to talk about color gold on let me
just pink this up yellow Michael
orange you're going to come to the
concert this evening I read about that
there gonna be a lot of purple there I
didn't tell you about this earlier well
look I have to go brown town first but
I'll be white black colors did you know
that the human eye can differentiate ten
million different colors but what color
is a mirror you might say silver because
mirrors are often Illustrated that way
and to be sure they are made out of
silver or silvery things like aluminum
but a mirror in reality is whatever
color you pointed at in this green room
the mirror is green and if you look
inside a mirror it becomes you colored
an object is whatever color it doesn't
absorb these sticky notes are orange
because when hit with typical white
light
they absorb every other wavelength of
visible light except for orange which
they diffuse into your eyeballs but a
perfect mirror reflects all colors
equally so in a way you could say that a
mirror is white except a mirror doesn't
reflect colors in the same way that
pigment does a mirror reflects incoming
light in a single outgoing direction
specular reflection not diffuse this
kind of reflection creates an image of
the very thing in front of the mirror so
as bad astronomy jokes a mirror is more
of a smart white but wait a second that
is a perfect mirror and we live in the
real world where there are no perfect
mirrors every mirror absorbs a little
bit of light not enough that it matters
I mean looks pretty clear to me but when
you take a look at the spectrum of light
reflected by a typical mirror you will
find that it best reflects light within
the 510 nanometer range which we
perceive as green light so technically a
mirror is a tiny
tiny tiny bit green you may have noticed
this yourself when investigating a
mirror tunnel this happens when two
mirrors face each other
reflecting the same scene back and forth
and back and forth and back and forth
with each new reflection a little bit
more visual light is lost but green
least of all that's why the reflection
way down the tunnel is dimmer and
greener
so maybe real-world mirrors aren't smart
white they're actually kind of green but
we should talk about white and española
white is Blanco of course a white city
blue and in English we have a word that
comes from the same root black which is
the opposite of white how did that
happen well it turns out that all of
those words come from the same ancient
proto-indo-european root word black
which meant shine burn flash some
languages took it to mean the brightness
of the flash white while others took it
to mean what's left behind the burned
black darkness if you have blue eyes
your eyes aren't actually blue in the
sense that the molecules inside them are
absorbing all of their wavelengths of
visible light and diffusing the blue no
no instead your eyes are blue for the
same reason that the sky is blue
interference in our sky light from the
Sun encounters molecules of air and
because of the size of those molecules
light of longer wavelengths can slip on
by but shorter wavelengths crash into
the particles like blue light and
scatter which is why we see blue when we
look at the sky away from the Sun
without the air molecules that space
would just be black and when direct
sunlight has to travel through a lot of
air almost all the colors get scattered
out except for the longest wavelengths
the red which is what gives a sunrise in
a sunset
their color the iris of your eyeball
contains a hazy layer where light can be
scattered just like the sky
a similar but slightly different process
shorter wavelengths are scattered more
making your eyes look blue unless of
course you have some melanin in that
iris in which case your eyes are going
to be green hazel or brown enjoy those
colors and as always thanks for watching
[Music]